hi welcome back to town of Salem with
gang this is the coven update including
15 new rolls a bunch of new game modes
and a coven only queue check it out on
Steam I don't have here so ugly you
deserve to die basically what he said so
yeah I mean being irrelevant and being
lined up for death I think are two
different things
no no no no no no no no wait are you out
of your gourd
he's got discord he's [ __ ] tree
guys please I don't think that death is
a goodness get the [ __ ] back in your
gourd dude haha yeah I did not like
turning [ __ ] oh yeah I think anal anal
turns to pili it or something like that
Killian yeah what anal turns to pillion
Bob stop giving me away eat it or GCSE
there's a roll bring it on down Oh Oh
what happens
Oh kill me Isaac [ __ ] me to kill me and
I something that sensor really [ __ ] up
because I I tried to kill me I guess
fund me and it totally ruined both of
those words I guess we knew he had more
of those who are list it was tiny tiny
and tits
there we go 4d knife sis yeah I'm sorry
I'm alive so who said my cell turn I
like it but this one is mine well my
well I'm nothing let me my will is
nothing why I said I was the spy I not
lie town is just [ __ ] somebody owes
me so you're all dead yeah alright so
I'm the escort who should I
tonight at tip tips real failure time
probably all right well I would like
escort hit big titties you want here
some kisses mmm
gotcha nailed it yeah I did that yeah
you're a good escort boy thank you when
YouTube fails me because the Paul bros
take you know because you know it will
every day oh my god
good God the [ __ ] happened oh yeah yeah
smelly now this is big of rigsy coven
verses to killing their go to bear meat
incinerated by an arsonist their psychic
what does the psychic actually do call
it beams guys horribly ah yeah i
distracted titties they're dead chat
believes in you lord
so she must have [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
0 1 0 0 1 0 0 1 0 0 1 month is at the
time code
yeah well to tell one great that's good
happy smile always friend you're the
line Tony
good luck Morgan I got it you can love
our arsonist at a hex master what
anybody for a good hahaha big giant also
a mark giant prostitutes Dana don't
worry about Lois facial expression -
he's just constantly just like
and weights this behind him like oh yay
get it daddy sit on me Santa daddy well
sex is just flashing over there crush me
with your giant Santa thighs I'd like to
have a connection I don't know what to
say no one's going up there
no one can vote I don't know why they're
not voting for you they can just [ __ ]
end this right now yeah
they are the town which one of them
should I distract tiny or sexy I know
it's one okay so well go all out with a
nice bag oh I'm on going sick yeah
that's why I got a good pattern here in
the other game the earlier game we
played we were we were mostly coven and
coven lost in this game we were all jaha
[ __ ] even though we started the rabbi
killing people to come in yeah the crew
second yeah we go the same way I was
what are the procedures even do we
protect or money somebody visits then we
kill them I think they're dragging this
out yeah new balls give me a decimal let
me know your house is happy Valentine's
Day light flashing so I'm going to come
into Valentine's hours I show you good
time with my man yet my Dominion can you
know hi based on backups wrong way very
Russian
I don't know I have your ass short plan
here do you want papers or are bahahaha
I got to you with my giant [ __ ] Oh funny
story my right arm is actually really
[ __ ] up they felt that of where my
penis used to be oh ha ha why are we
voting
tiny like sure sure let's go with this
one cares
is that the arsonist is sexy gonna now
try and kill you infinite loop can you
just distract them everybody maybe yeah
you don't have a limited number of
distractions right you can bone every
night all night hahaha come to born
palace hey sexy you want again okay
hahaha a different escort is you know
this is you know back - keepers I don't
understand what are you guys going to
Santa oh no man no 24 century Russia or
something I knew Santa was Paul brothers
everyday bro oh why are you worried
April this is oh yeah looks like I got
visited right away anyway so I would be
dead from the arsons but I didn't die
from the crusader looks like epoch looks
like I'm going to have another fun out
of this I don't know deliver all of your
presence I'm going to deliver millions
of presents huh huh huh huh huh huh hey
rose Santa comes down your chimney
delivery across the lines
yeah and that was not okay what the hell
man Santa don't care Santa you another
beautiful day thank you friend how many
turns does it take to draw it today keep
going oh if you could indicate a Russian
accent when you typed I wish there was a
symbol for this
backwards r's in what you're typing just
for random backwards r's
unrelated to the actual Cyrillic
characters just like this it's Russian
pillow says happy smiles kind of
annoying well now you're a frog great
the [ __ ] do we do I'm still the truth I
let you cheat why are they both Russian
Russian who acted funny watching you
look I don't like some more today ger
hybrid s sound like Schwarzenegger get
in the chopper
look aa Russian either I think maybe
pushing pencils Jews so would you guys
got me back give up or something or you
know don't about school yourself
okay I'm into submission madam I need to
submit that's course sexy I did give up
give up oh we wouldn't just lead lead
tomorrow with I will not stop tarnation
in you until you let me win it happens
one stagnation without turning you into
a frog oh look a lot of Hobbiton okay
maybe next time were you believe a
never-ending game can can i it's by
pushing the girl just wait just roll
them into leaving that's how you win oh
the great of times I don't know what
I've ever seen a draw in this game it's
gotta at some point it's got to just cut
off returns or something when it when
they realize that it's a draw but
apparently not they didn't plan in the
coven expansion for this to happen
wait no the escort wasn't me escort like
a basic one yeah yeah escorts a regular
role
yeah can you vote for him not to vote
you needed [ __ ]
vote for yourself though for yourself I
can't sooner or later
oh wait so on things that Santa might be
poisoned already good doesn't would I
know that or would I not know that I
don't know I didn't notice that I was
you don't get to know when you're like
doused or poisoned or anything anymore
that's a bell you know if you need you
need to offer people I believe a so much
here so don't be press that window
she'll be picked up a moose it's working
every time I shall be myself billion you
want you want you want wild ride
they can't be pissed drop in Mentos and
then shove up ass crazy throw and a pro
[ __ ] somebody high got it they say the
Big Brother only mark would die and it
would tell him if he did
oh no make my money in seven never died
in the supply
good job Mars review threw it out it's
gonna be you and butterflies [ __ ]
forever I'm tired to tarnation you each
night what the hell every night when Sun
go down the blackout I wake up to you
next morning in bed totally satisfied
simply by all Salem white at this root
key key key key key key every day every
day Christmas it wait
Belle isn't one of us is it is that one
of us usually when he can have crackle
pop and iris tarnation
I was Alice young lapel is actually just
awesome well one mutual admiration I
like the way to heaven so you guys had
gone on during the day there yeah good
stuff good stuff
[Laughter]
this isn't a quality content yeah golly
I was stimulating does elf I'm sorry you
guys are so bored I died thank you for
today it's been a long time since I've
had direction of blood you've had
platoon Oh
vente get more 364 days no action save
up for one night I think this is a good
episode oh okay so to draw yeah draw
yeah nobody wins and yeah hahahahaha
boner Dern sticker
[Laughter]
[Music]